hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from round 10 of the 2018
Batumi Chess Olympiad the match is China
versus Poland and on board one we'd have
Eliran dinga of China vs. Yankees to
Judah and now we already mentioned that
to do the head some incredible
encounters in the four previous matches
he is playing board one for Poland and
they are playing excellently so we
already mentioned he defeated vastly one
choke and then three games in a row he
drew against chakra dear mama dro then
he drew against Levin Aragon and then he
drew in the previous round against the
World Chess Championship challenger
Fabiano Caruana now he faces yet another
member of the 2800 club it's a linear
ending and it really is a very
impressive game but before we go to the
game I don't know how many of you are
actually following what goes on in feed
a feed it has a new president the new
president of fides Arkady dvorkovich
there you have it it's this gentleman
after a nice photo by David Lada now
Arkady at work which was a member of the
organization committee for the 2018 FIFA
World Cup in Russia so definitely a
competent man and I'm very eager to see
what changes might occur in fidei I
wouldn't go so far as to you know that's
an edge Medina will actually be given a
Grand Master title but you know it's a
step by step perhaps we'll get there and
also here we have a very nice photo of
Nigel short shaking Vladimir Kramnik
and as you know Nigel short was also in
the race for the feat a presidency but
he backed out in the last moment and
then right after the elections he
announced that he is now the new feed a
vice president so there you have it a
bit of news from free day now let's
check out this very nice game
leerin opens the width d4 we have Knight
to f6
c4 e6 knife to f3 let me just fix that
and of course we transpose into the
Queens gambit declined with the d5
Knight to c3 we have d captures on c5
and now e4 a very sharp line
b5 this is one of the few lines of the
Queens gambit where it is actually okay
to defended the sea
for pawn we have E 5 nights to D 5 and
now Knight captures on b5 we have nice
to b6 and Bishop to e2 and it's very
interesting this game follows a game
that was played in the Sinquefield Cup
between mama D aravind Caruana but it
also follows a game that was already
played by Duda with the black pieces he
played it against tirado's la voiture
shock in the Poland champ polish
championship in 2018 we had Knight to c6
castles and now Bishop to e7 and this is
the moment where Caruana played a Madero
played Bishop to e3 against Cara Juana
and also a void a shock played the
Bishop to e3 against the Duda so here is
the moment where dingos Queen to d2 and
now we have a completely new game that
was never played before the disposition
is not available in the database so
definitely a nice home preparation
bye-bye Duda sorry Bob I think we have
castles and the now comes Queen to f4
the difference between these this game
and the game boy - Shrek Duda is that in
that game this bishop was developed to
e3 and then Bishop was played to g5 then
the bishops got exchanged and only then
did the Queen come to f4 here dink has
different plans for this Bishop and see
one group to b8 and now Knight back to
c3 not allowing the knight can be five
to stay a target and now e five if I
have a very nice move controlling the
Foursquare not allowing ideas like 94
but also it pretty much inviting this um
passant capture on f6 because now after
rook captures to attack the Queen Queen
has to move and now Knight the before
will be will be very annoying and that
black would black would be doing great
here perhaps even Knight 2 d 3 with an
idea of giving up the CC pawn the the
double spawn for the bishop pair would
also be an idea so after f5 Queen to g3
biding and it's very interesting didn't
really spend only a few seconds for
every move here we have King to h8 a
very important move because whatever
your plan is this Bishop to h6 will
always be a possibility
for example if you go for this sort of
free porn with night after Sun before
then night capture Sun before Queen
captures and now comes the bishop to h6
and there's really nothing to play here
the thread is Queen to g7 checkmate you
can't block with the rook milady six and
allow Bishop captures rook because now
Bishop to h5 is an idea and now g6
doesn't work because of the simple
Bishop captures H captures Queen
captures and now it's all over
there's really nothing to play here King
goes here Queen captures white is
thought completely winning here so after
Queen to g3 first Duda goes for King to
h8 rook to d1 now defending the d4 pawn
and now we have Knights the b4 with
ideas of this knife coming to c2 or
perhaps even d3 and here we have b3 by
dink and this is in fact the strongest
move now ideas like Knight 2 D 3 are
pretty much pointless simply be
characters on c4 and this Knight is just
silly here Knight captures on c1 yes you
do grab a bishop but then after rook
captures on c1 you have this monster
Center where d5 when it comes it will
really hurt so after b3 simply seek
after some b300 now a capture some b3 a
semi-open file for a dings rook and the
a7 point is under attack you do have to
do something about this we have a six
sometimes you just have to defend the
pawn and here comes bush up to see for a
very nice move where again ding is
inviting this cap front c4 because again
the end result would be this monster
bone formation in the center so after
Bishop to c4 we have Knights the c2 with
an attack on the rook and here dink
plays rook to a two-night back to before
by Duda rook to a 1 and the Knights the
detail with this move Duda is pretty
much offering a draw if King is willing
to repeat moves then we will have a draw
by repetition
rook to a2 and again nice to be four and
now if ding repeats rook to a1 one more
time
it will indeed be draw by a threefold
repetition so here ding really took his
time and he calculates a very nice idea
he plays rook to eat
we have a five and now comes d5 a very
nice idea
you don't just push a pawn like this in
the center if you don't if you don't
have something to back it up so what's
the idea we have it captures on d5 by
Judah this is definitely alright and now
II six very interesting okay it's a very
nice past pawn on e6 the bishop cannot
be captured for a moment as is the point
is pinned at the Queen this rook is very
nicely x-raying the Queen so what do you
do here the best idea ended the best
defensive resource for black here it
seems to be rook to f6 simply with a
double attack against the e6 pawn and
now after Knight to g5 defending the
pawn now King to g8 you don't want to
allow tonight to f7 to count with check
picking up the Queen or you would have
to give up the rook but doesn't really
matter but now after Knight to f7 you
have Queen to f8 and getting the Queen
out of the way at the pawn is no longer
pin so now pawn captures Bishop is
definitely an idea and after the bishop
moves and now you capture the pawn rook
captures on e6 and black is better here
so it seems Duda did not continue in the
best way possible rather he had a
different idea
he played Bishop to d6 okay it comes
with an attack on the Queen and also now
the rook is no longer x-raying the Queen
pawn captures Bishop is a possibility
now so what was things idea here Queen
to h3 and okay you already see that some
Knights to g5 Queen h7 business is about
to break here and D captures on c4 is a
bit too soon because here as we
mentioned Knight to g5 and after h6
Knight to f7 check rook captures pawn
captures and now there is no there is no
defense against rook to d8 if you try to
block it with something like Bishop to
d7 or simply blocking it with Bishop to
f8 then Bishop captures and h6 is coming
and black is completely busted there's
there's no defense gear Bishop to g5
will be checkmate as the point is
covering the g8 Square and of course if
you capture them simply Queen captures
will be checkmate okay so after Queen to
h3 you can't capture the bishop just yet
so first Queen to f6
the best defensive idea and here it's
really not all that clear how they can
continue
attack I mean you kinda do have to
continue this attack as you as if given
a pawn but how do you continue it and
here Dean spend some thirty something
minutes and it's it's really a very nice
move it's not true even it's not even
clear how how such a thing is possible
but here he actually doesn't move his
Bishop rather he plays Knight to b5 and
here it's it's not a moment where I want
you to pause the video a video and find
something it's just you know try to try
to figure out how is this compensation
for the for the bishop I don't want you
even to pause the video because I mean
ding spent 30 minutes on it if you're
willing to spend 30 minutes on it then
by all means do but you know yeah I I
don't think it would be possible so Duda
accepts the bishop sacrifice D captures
and C were before was played Knight
captures on d6 we have C captures on d6
and now comes east 7 and okay you're
passed pawn is marching forward rook to
e8 blocking the pass pawn and here we
have Knight to g5 threatening checkmate
so if you look at the position now you
do have a passed pawn on e7 guarded by
protected by the rook the other rook is
very nicely placed on d1 you do have a
knight on d5 Queen on h3 already
threatening checkmate you do have to
deal with this so part of the
compensation for the piece is that these
nights are very oddly placed the rook
isn't really doing all that much and
this Bishop for now again not not not
too great of a piece perhaps after f4
will be played then it might come alive
but for now the placement of blacks
pieces is compensation in itself so what
do you do here you cannot stop it with
h6 if you try h6 then you don't play
rook to d6 it seems like a very nice
idea Queen captures and then nice to f7
picks up the Queen with check what here
you have a problem because now f4
attacks the Queen and now it's actually
black that's winning once you move the
Queen on the other hand after h6 like I
said you don't capture immediately but
first you have this Queen to h5 now all
of these threats are possible also now
that
attacking the rook and once you defend
the rook Bishop to d7 only now do you
get a rope captures here and now there
is no F for to attack White's Queen and
an h3 and now you're simply lost either
Queen captures and the knight f7 picks
up the Queen or if you don't do this if
you try and move the Queen let's say
Queen to e5 then simply rook captures on
h6 Punk after screen captures and it is
all over now
King g8 Queen to h7 will be checkmate so
after 95 Queen g6 the best defensive
resource by Judah preventing Queen to h5
so how do you proceed here well there's
no time for a slow move rook captures on
d6 as planned now you don't have time to
capture it because Knight f7 wins the
Queen so first f-4s planned the Queen is
now under attack
dink proceeds with Queen to h4 keeping
all of his options open the Queen is
still under attack the same threat still
applies if Queen captures knight of
seven check so here we have Queen to b1
and Queen to be won
seems like seems like it guards
everything the threat is of course Queen
captures Bishop but now it's not all
that clear
rook Queen captures on f4 guards the
bishop and the threatens Queen to f8 and
perhaps this would have been the best
idea for white after Bishop to d7 it's
it's not all that easy to see how white
proceeds here but adding finds a
different idea you've simply defends
with rook to e1 the bishop is now
guarded and here the position is
holdable or tenable as someone already
mentioned in the comments but with a
move like Bishop to d7 you can still
hold here as the rook is guarded there's
no there's no way to actually push for
for something here with white but
White's eternal a black's eternal
problem is that the the position of his
pieces is just weird and this is
something that is often a case in chess
it's much easier to attack them to
defend often when you attack there will
be that one move that helps you but when
you're defending you have like this
whole variety of options and you have no
idea which one is actually here
the one that will prevent you from
losing the game so here with Bishop to
d7 Duda could still hold the disposition
but he played Bishop to f5 and Bishop to
f5 loses the game how does Bishop to f5
lose the game and Bishop to d7 doesn't
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning move that ding
indeed played in this game I'll give you
a couple of seconds to decide what do we
want to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you have just defeated a very strong
player who we already said beat vastly
von Schuch and drew against some some of
the top 5 chess players in the world and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show the ideas rook to da and now it
becomes obvious if the bishop was on d7
rook to d8 would not be a possibility so
what do you do here of course you cannot
capture the rook if you capture Knight
to have seven wins immediately the king
is in check you have to move now Knight
captures the threat is point to e 8 this
will bring a queen and it is all over if
you try to prevent this doesn't really
matter
simply Queen and after capture captures
it's checkmate the knight is covering
the f7 square so after rook to the 8th
do that right Bishop to g6 but now we
have rook capture Sun b8
you do have to capture it rod captures
and now comes Queen captures on f4
everything is defended there's really
not all that much to do here 0.28 is
definitely a threat so do that ride on a
rock to g8 rook to e8 doesn't help you
either because then simply Queen to f8
you give up the Queen for a nice
checkmate so rock 2g it was played and
now comes nice to have 7 check pawn
captures Queen captures again you're
you're dead lost here if we play any
move then Queen captures rook will be
will be checkmate after King captures
you simply bring another Queen to
deliver checkmate so do that right
Knight to d7 trying to bring the knight
over to f6 to help out with the defense
but it is much too late I'm do that
would have probably given up already if
it wasn't a team event but you do have
to try we have another Queen on the
board
and now Knight to f6 it's very hard to
imagine that a white could actually
blunder the game here it would have to
be something like Queen captures Knight
captures and then a threatening
checkmate where black would be allowed
to play something like this and deliver
checkmate
but of course Dingley rain is not
undefeated for over 80 games for for
blundering moves like this here are
simply Bishop to g5 was played and now
unmoved a 38 it was in this position
that yan xishan of Duda resigned to the
game so there we have it a very nice win
there's really nothing to do here his
queen is under attack the threat is
you're gonna capture this night and then
deliver checkmate and pretty much
whatever you play even you grab the
Queen then rook captures Queen you are
down a queen simply losing so yeah after
Bishop to g5 Duda resign the game and
yet another game added hunted England's
undefeated streak which is now I'm not
sure I think it's around 85 games so
still not not close to circuit TV
archives world record but you know the
way he's playing I think it's oh it's
been over a year now since the last game
he lost but yeah too bad for an dude as
he was having an excellent tournament
but you know a ding ding is really doing
incredible stuff here and I don't know
III can't even imagine how exciting the
next candidate cycle will be and just so
I don't forget these are the standings
after round 10 so one more round to go
in 2018 but to me chess Olympiad United
States and China in first place followed
by Poland France Russia India Armenia
Ukraine Germany Czech Republic England
Kazakhstan Vietnam Croatia Norway in 15
Sweden Moldova Austria Philippines and
Azerbaijan in 20 which is a pretty
incredible as they were as they were you
know serving first place just a few
rounds ago but that's just for you
anything can happen so there we have it
United States of America and China
tomorrow are deciding the winner of the
Olympiad it will be World Chess
Championship challenge or Fabiano
Khurana against the Dingley rain so can
Ken Fabiano do something about this
undefeated streak illyrians been having
for the past year or will it will it be
a bit different and it's very
interesting Nakamura did not play today
ray Robson was a substitute for him and
the United States won their today's
match so it will be very interesting if
Nakamura will be playing tomorrow
against China so there we have it a
little a little coverage of the 2018 but
to me chess olympiad I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you have enjoyed
this game I certainly have I would like
to thank David Rossi Karpinski eilat
Zamir Timothy J Buxton and John Farooq
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here think'll for watching and
I'll see you soon
definitely with our a game or two from
the last round of the Olympiad and
hopefully finally continuing the Bobby
Fischer series thank you all and I'll
see you soon